Jamal Crawford is here we are going to
Blind rank Lakers and Celtics greats in
honor of winning Time season 2 Jamal are
you ready I am so ready for this this is
history first up Magic Johnson two wow
Larry Bird Three next one up that they
sent me Kareem Abdul Jabar one all right
now it gets spicy Bill
Russell one two three felt so good it
felt so right he has to go for now and
now is when it's going to really grind
your gears you better not say it Kobe
Bryant oh my I'm wearing Kobe today this
is supposed to be he was number one on
my list oh my gosh so you're telling me
that you're putting Kobe fifth you did
like you just did it how do you feel
Kobe Bryant is not fifth on any list
ever in basketball history he is on your
blind
ranking